c'est une question pour vous à l'iss
qu'est ce qui vous a convaincu de
réaliser chambre de 102
[Musique]
je crois que la seule raison valable
pour faire un film c'est un désir
irrépressible
[Musique]
c'est à 10 dinars
je me demandais pourquoi vous voyez plus
[Musique]
quand j'ai lu le script j'ai senti que
j'avais pas le choix
faire ce film c'était une question sur
[Musique]
et ne croyez pas les gens qui disent
qu'on peut tout avoir sans prendre aucun
risque
parce que c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
et il peut arriver que des personnes
pour même
de tuer
[Musique]
oh
il peut arriver que les personnes qu'on
ait manqué ce qui s'est passé ça fait
sans doute partie rejet
entre ciel que ça en vaille la peine
[Musique]
vous estimez que ça en valait la peine